we're going to focus on the social the
social sort of meaning of eating
together why we do this and actually
what makes this really exciting is that
eating together might be or differs us
humans from other hungry animals on this
planet have you thought of that so I
would like you to welcome our panel here
first of all we have Christiana Newsline
full heart and applauded to her this is
until recently she was director of the
Max Planck Institute of developmental
biology at tubingen in Germany she's
doing research on the complexity of life
in the cell she's doing genetic research
you used to do it on on fruit flies
nowadays cebra fish I've understood so
soon you will be covering the human
being as well we don't know she was
awarded a nobel prize for medicine or
physiology 1995 she's back here with us
today the next distinguished guests here
another applause welcome back thank you
she has also written a book but we'll
come back to that later many low rates
do that but this is this is a
cliffhanger so please professor richard
raynham he has also written books of
course and this one is called catching
fire so please give him a warm hand
catching fire
he's a professor of biological
biological anthropology at Harvard
University you studied select so logic
geology why is this so hard ecology
about animals cambridge UK and since 30
years back this guy has followed wild
chimpanzees in kabbalah national park in
gonda and studied their behavior and
he's of course very interested in how we
became humans so that will be something
hmmm last but not least claude fischler
this is the soft sociologists and
anthropologists of the panel expert on
common sanity do you know what that is
most of you are Swedish but perhaps you
know latin the word Mensa meaning table
so common table sit together in it god
I'm right now commonality is eating
together and you have been director of
the interdisciplinary institute
institute for contemporary anthropology
in paris and two recently and also he
was the research director of the
National Research Center of France and
so there we are and first of all talking
about common salary i would like to ask
you actually with hands up now how many
of you had dinner last night with your
family screen free sitting down by a
dinner table eating together no screens
not by the telly not checking your
emails are okay you will change your
mind after this session as a gentleman
sir please may i start with you Richard
because this about catching fire the way
we we managed to do that two million
years ago wasn't it and how and how this
sort of changed not only the nutrients
in the meat
actually made us be able to take more
nutrients from the meat so we could do
other things than catching me isn't that
one of the benefits of catching the fire
yeah I mean so far today we've been
talking tirely about food production mmm
we haven't talked about food preparation
at all and it's only recently that
people have realized that the way in
which we cook has extraordinary impacts
on the nutrients and we still know
relatively little about it but how much
extra energy do we get from cooking our
food it's something around maybe thirty
percent fifty percent extra calories net
and this is odd because if you look at
global sources of information about
foods and you ask yourself the question
for foods that are eaten I possibly raw
or possibly cooked what does the USDA
website or any other website tell us
about how many calories we get and the
answer typically is slightly fewer if we
eat it raw sorry slightly fewer if we're
cooked yeah and this was just testing us
there if we were listening thank you
exactly right reciprocate it's okay so
the fact is that that's what the science
tells us is not represented in the
public information available and and if
we're going to think about efficient use
of our food then we should really be
prepared to understand the science of
what cooking does of course in terms of
the nutrients sometimes it goes in one
way and sometimes goes in another there
are some vitamins that are reduced by
cooking and there are others that are
increased so we need a whole lot more
information about exactly how much the
impact of cooking has affected us and
you asked about how long has been going
on and it's a matter of debate among
anthropologists but it certainly has
gone on for a million years and and I
think it made us human i think it's gone
back two million years how did it all
start how did your stone well we were
sitting there by the fire look once
you're sitting there by the fire it
would take about a week
to figure out that you should cook
although we've tested all of the great
apes and chimpanzees gorillas orangutans
bonobos they all prefer their food
cooked but that's not unusual Oh animals
do dogs do cats do rats do mice do every
animal understands that their food
perception system is adapted to seeing
where the most energy comes from in
their foods so the question is how do
they get into contact with fire exactly
are we near time shy accident yeah might
have been because it gets more tasty
well I mean if you want to think about
it then very likely the way in which we
interacted with fire first was to use it
as a way to defend against predators
that meant we could come down from the
trees and sleep on the ground as soon as
you're interacting with fire on a
regular basis then very quickly food
would fall into the fire and you would
realize that this is worth perpetuating
it's worth it mm-hmm and Dan christiani
and the book you have written having did
you bring it oh no it's me it's it's
back there oh I have written book so you
have written so many books but no no no
this is a cookbook I know that's what I
want you to tell us yeah I'm and i'ma
turn in cooking and and I'm a scientist
but I love to cook and I like to cook
for guests and I have frequently after
dinner parties where I invite people I'd
like to join me and friends who want to
talk oh also colleagues who who I want
to bring together at one table to solve
difficult problems and the food has a
wonderful ability to make them sort of
smiling and annoying and being on a
better mood and I think this is the
essential a thing of eating together is
having interesting conversations
stimulated by sharing something by
sharing a common meal and I think that
is a very very important social social
good you and did you do this before you
receive the Nobel Prize so it was
actually a success factor no I'm growing
I grew up in a family with many children
we had regular meals together and the
meals were sort of
formalized we had trust we had two be
quiet we had our soup together and then
we had had good conversations and I
thought it was really important and I
try to keep that up in my lab for
example when I invite my people for
sometimes a party when they celebrate
thesis defense or when we have a visitor
also and it's often a really
entertaining and very import isn't this
land you need to spend the whole
afternoon in the kitchen because you
know I colleagues ho microwave actually
is the topic is simple food for special
occasions this is the subtitle meaning
that you have to be able to cook
something which doesn't embarrass your
guests because they think oh god this
poor woman spend all the time in the
kitchen and also when the guests come
you must not you must not be nervous you
must be sort of as if you hadn't done
anything because it would also spoil the
atmosphere if you spend too much too
much effort to actually write in the
forward of your book here and I take it
in English at dinner invitations the
most important things is that people are
in good mood and have pleasurable an
interesting conversation yes so this is
it this is the point yeah and when you
are running around in rushing around
saying oh gods cooked and you know if we
found and and apologize all that this is
embarrassing for people so you shouldn't
do that one trip this way we should just
enjoy it thank you you make it seem so
easy but please caught the fish lurking
you know comment on what we've heard
from from your perspective that's it I
would like to call an expert now on oh
well I'd like to start I I could ask you
a question you said you like to cook for
France this is not a daily occasion it's
an extraordinary occasion you invite
people now what happens if someone
doesn't like what you're cooking how do
you feel about that I try to find out
beforehand and so she's the hostess are
thoroughly are the vegetarians and and
and I try to if they are vegetarians I
try to make a vegetarian meal for
everyone because I find it embarrassing
if people get the extra say
so I try to find out and I usually have
I think mostly yeah I don't think I had
these kind of discipline my question was
not exactly that but so what someone
you've invited and you've taken all the
precautions as to what their diet is and
their dietary requirements and then some
reason they don't finish their plate or
they obviously don't like it how do you
feel I'm a bet I'm I has never happened
I very very rarely very rarely but
sometimes I'm offended and I think it's
not done at my point exactly so in you
in violence you eat but you get up there
we are exactly so that's that and that's
a pretty red relatively I mean
anthropologists are always uncomfortable
seeing a sentence like this is a
universal right if there's always
someone that will come up with a Mary
Douglas once told me here there's always
someone in the room that will say excuse
me but I'm working with the bongo bongos
and it's not at all the case but
generally spanning generally speaking
what you describe is typically the for
instance I got an answer for am an
interviewee in a in a survey and she
said oh if someone doesn't like what I
cook for them it's like you know I want
to give them a kiss and they turn the
cheek away mm-hmm it's just a refusal
now because it's interesting because you
share something isn't it interesting
that we now have affected we now have
apparently a growing number of cases in
which admittedly there is an exception
to this rule that is you go to someone
and instead of by default accepting to
eat what they're going to give you you
convey turn your preferences or
restrictions or whatever the reciprocity
is gone in that case and what happened
I'm not saying it's right or wrong I
mean not
just observing so it's different from
country to country in my country for
instance about 3% people when asked say
I'm a vegetarian we saw here today 23%
in this audience we know that in Britain
it's about usually twelve percent or
even more so there are huge differences
and basically we we are thinking
increasingly in the Western developed
world in terms of individuals making
choices and come to think of it it's an
entire novelty I mean choice is a recent
invention and it was not the place where
you should have that choice is that what
you say you should actually I'm not
saying what you should or shouldn't do
I'm trying to observe and boyfriends
this for instance in a recent poll the
front that the French sample was asked
what do you do exactly what I asked what
do you do if you're invited at some once
and you don't like what is certain word
to you and sixty-eight percent say I
force myself hmm now we have applied
similar questions asked to Americans and
to other people so whether they are
sincere or not but we get very different
answers and so what can we learn from
this when it comes to how important it
is together and prepare me as together
what do you say Christina well I have to
think we have to realize that we are in
a changing world and there are some
assumptions including some things that
have been said today we make it sound
pretty often that it's only a matter of
getting more choices more options and
being more autonomous and freer and what
I observe what we observe is that in
countries where there is this autonomy
intagram we're not going to criticize
autonomy I think it's a conquest answer
but it comes with problems and people
have a hard time making choices they
keep hearing about the right choice the
healthy choice and similarly there's a
guitar funny of advice and and
recommendations around and we have a
hard time dealing with
don't prioritize this well i think in
western countries where people really
have a super I mean have all choices of
food they are much too much concerned
about the health of the moon I mean
they're totally I mean these discussions
about whether sugar is good or bad or
whether we should eat more this or that
and then some people commented I don't
eat okay I did I don't I don't eat
cereals I don't you took out or
something I think it's overdone I mean
it's because we have too rich mm-hmm you
know and I mean when I grew up food was
something really wonderful and I was
always hungry I always ate too much and
and and i think it's just maybe it's my
upbringing but i think it's very bad
manners to but this is researching
nothing about the things which are yeah
but people have so many concerns and
then it must be free of this and free of
that and you know and and they have read
something in the newspaper that fungi
are dangerous and celery is bad and you
know in these things and i think it's
it's totally unnatural it's not it's if
it was you sir who do you say Richard
about this from your point of well the
point about autonomy and food choice i
think is part of a larger issue about
autonomy in eating autonomy in the topic
of this thing they've the extent to
which we eat together or alone right and
to get actually i'm i'm impressed by
Claude's point that the whole concept of
having choice about this is relatively
novel yeah it's too you know if we think
about our evolutionary psychology we
grew up in small-scale societies where
people always there together and what I
love about the the work that's been done
on that in terms of Education which is
emerging repeatedly today as a such an
important theme about how we modify our
food systems of the future is that
education goes on around the meals and
around the campfires so so when the
anthropologist Polly wiesner looked at
what people talk about in small-scale
societies then by day they talk about
practical things economic things
maybe a little bit of social sanctioning
to stop people doing the wrong thing but
then I comes the meal and people sitting
around the fire and that is when people
start reflecting in an entirely
different way now they tell stories now
they tell myths now that you
reconstitute the cultural institutions
and in our terms you know they would be
thinking about things that's important
for the society and in ways that are
often enthralling and exciting stories
are told that engender a sense of unity
and a sense of commitment to the future
which in many ways were lacking by our
autonomy if we go off and eat alone
which of course in small-scale society
your regardless as mad or depressed if
you want to eat alone but if we do that
we we miss so much opportunity for we do
bonding around the meal and you know
what you're in this little conversation
that is now about to end I'm afraid we
have been served some food but it didn't
really work because we were are you
talking's because I gave our discussion
I cannot bring myself to eat something
in front of an audience of a 1000 you
have never actually starving well yeah
then fine yep Stacy had my Stacy says
yeah you're too polite you should tuck
in cut your palm down for you to enjoy
so an epic deal is and in fact it would
be very good what you did though and
forth myself please do because I lost
thank you thank you so much all of you
and
[Applause]